no what's interesting is like okay
because you like games like
banjo-kazooie or like jrpgs where
there's like a whole like
collect like a collecting element to it
right yeah like linear games more than
open world and stuff like that i i do
like linear games more than openly right
i like it's funny because i feel like
i do like the idea of open world games
but if i'm gonna sit down and play
something then i much prefer linear
games
right because one of my favorite aspects
of animal crossing personally is like
the whole like
catching fish and bugs and collecting
all the artworks and collecting all the
furniture
like it's basically the collecting
portion of it right whereas a lot of
other people who play the game you know
enjoy the whole like you know
diy you know creating your own amazing
looking town amazing looking house kind
of thing to me that's like
second yeah number one for me is
definitely like i need to complete my
fish index i need to complete my bug
index
why why why do you want to do that
because i got that love
from playing all the jrpgs right and
like and
obviously six is up there because like
there was that for six
for me as well but like i think the
reason why i picked six and i think
why final fantasy vi is my favorite not
only final fantasy game but my favorite
jrpg ever
yeah is because like it was the first
game where i was like this is a work of
art right like this is like not just a
game it's like the gameplay is like
cool you know i've played all the
previous final fantasies like four and
one and [ __ ] like that
right the gameplay is basically the same
but six was the first time where i was
like
i didn't know story could be this good i
didn't know game music
could be this good i didn't know you
could have this much
immersion in a game yeah where and i got
to like the fight
like the fact that you know people still
talk to this day about like the final
fight scene right yeah yeah yeah fine
like six like final fantasy 6 i feel
like it's
overshadowed by final fantasy vii but
everyone i know who's played final
fantasy 6 holds it higher than the final
fantasy 7 i've always said the true
final fantasy that's like
six is the true final fantasy fans pick
yeah yeah right because it's like
you're not persuaded by like the
graphics quote unquote because this was
the last
2d final fantasy iron seven is roblox
yeah seven is roblox but people still
put it on this [ __ ] like pedestal of
graphics right it's like
what are you seeing and like you know
don't get me wrong seven is also a good
game
yeah i also like seven but six was i
don't know there's something about it
where i was like
this game could look like absolute [ __ ]
right and
the story and the music and everything
just the immersion of getting into this
world is so
[ __ ] well done yeah where it's like i
don't care how this game looks
um yeah it was yeah like to this day
like the [ __ ]
battle thing the decisive battle theme
from final fantasy 6 gives me a [ __ ]
heart on
every time i listen to it it's like
persona 5 and final fantasy 6
to easily have the best [ __ ] battle
theme music of
any game i mean i can't comment really i
haven't played any final fantasy so i
feel bad i can't
judge you there's a lot of there's a lot
of final fantasy i mean like
we've talked about hating turn-based
battles yeah i am regretting
uh not putting i wish i put runescape on
my list now
oh yeah i'm surprised runescape wasn't
on your list i played runescape that was
like the first game i ever like had a
membership for
actually maybe club penguin yeah club
penguin wasn't the first one for me
penguin on my list dude going on those
[ __ ] tubes down there
the snow slope tipping the ice becoming
like definitely like when you say
emotion in the world man i was so into
those [ __ ] quests and [ __ ] oh yeah
going to like monkey island and stuff oh
my god
so good put runescape on my list yeah i
i i want to remake my 3x3 after talking
to you guys about it i could honestly
make a 3x3 of like
each console